hello and welcome to math simplified in
this video we will talk about five
natural home remedies that you can try
if you are suffering from dandruff
dandruff also known as seborrheic
dermatitis
is actually an extremely common skin
condition experienced by most people
at some point in their lives regardless
of ethnicity
age or gender it tends to affect not
just the scalp
but also the eyebrows the ears the beard
and the hairy part of the chest in our
previous videos about dandruff we have
discussed in detail about what is
dandruff
how to prevent and treat dandruff so
make sure to watch that video for a
detailed understanding of why dandruff
occurs
as this will help you to manage your
condition in a better way
hello i'm dr umar malik and let's
discuss the five
best natural home remedies that you can
use if you have dandruff
now the first natural home remedy that
i'm gonna share with you belongs to
ayurveda
ayurvedic medicine or ayurveda is a
holistic healing system
that originated from the indian
subcontinent around 3000 years ago
and it has many successful home remedies
and practices for managing dandruff
now since i belong to india working in a
dermatology department
awoke my interest in ayurvedic products
because they work very good for
conditions of hair and skin and the
first natural ayurvedic treatment that
you can try for treating dandruff
is neem oil neem is a natural herb that
comes from the neem tree
other names for which include as a
director indica
and indian lilac ancient ayurvedic texts
describe
neem tree as sarva rogan which means
universal healer or curer of all
ailments
neem oil derived from this tree is a
very potent agent
with antiseptic antibacterial and
antifungal properties
the primary cause of dandruff is fungi
known as malassezia or sometimes candida
also
now the antifungal properties of neem
oil make it effective against these
fungi
you can also use neem oil to get relief
from inflammation
itchiness and irritation that results
from dandruff
for those who are prone to dandruff neem
oil should be used regularly
it also helps in maintaining the ph
balance of the scalp
which further prevents dandruff
formation
to use neem oil to get rid of dandruff
naturally
dilute equal parts of neem oil with
almond or sesame oil
and gently massage the oil directly into
the roots of the hair and scalp
after allowing it to work for 30 minutes
cleanse your hair with a natural
cleanser
number two tea tree oil tea tree oil is
incredibly useful product for a lot of
ailments and dandruff is definitely one
of them
tea tree oil has got antimicrobial and
anti-inflammatory properties
that help to reduce the severity and
symptoms of dandruff a 2006 study found
that a shampoo with five percent tea
tree oil was used with positive results
a current study also found that tea tree
oil shampoo produced a 78
reduction in microbial growth on the
scalp now it is very effective for
fighting the strains of fungus which
cause both dandruff and seborrheic
dermatitis
it is crucial to dilute tea tree oil
properly with either water or carrier
oil before using
otherwise it can cause irritation
especially for those of us who happen to
have
sensitive skin one way to use tea tree
oil for
hair is to prepare a hair spray by
diluting five percent tea tree oil with
water
or chamomile tea this will condition the
hair and
also prevent dandruff number three apple
cider vinegar
apple cider vinegar is made from
fermented apple juice
it helps to remove the dead skin cells
and balance the ph
of the scalp apple cider vinegar
contains acetic acid
which is a weak acidic solution and it
helps to lower the ph level of the scalp
which reduces dandruff symptoms there
are many studies that show that it can
prevent the growth of many types of
fungi
a 2019 study concluded that undiluted
apple cider vinegar has
potent antimicrobial activity to use it
combine two to three tablespoons of
apple cider vinegar with
same amount of water then put it on your
scalp and let it sit for a few minutes
before
rinsing your hair with clear water or
washing your hair with a mild shampoo
you can also add few drops of apple
cider vinegar to your bathtub to restore
the ph balance of your body and hair
number four aloe vera not only is aloe
vera cooling
but also mildly exfoliates the skin and
has
antifungal and antibacterial properties
it is best to directly extract some from
the aloe vera plant
it is transparent and has a thick
consistency
it can be applied on the scalp and then
washed off with a medicated
anti-dandruff or mild shampoo
aloe vera could be used in multiple ways
for your hair and scalp
aloe vera hair masks prepared at home
are also very effective
you can also mix aloe vera with castor
oil mix 4 tablespoons of castor oil in
3 tablespoons of aloe vera gel apply
this oil
on your hair and scalp and massage for a
few minutes
wash the hair with lukewarm water after
2 hours
do this once a week for a month to see
good results
aloe vera can also be combined with tea
tree oil
you can mix 3 drops of tea tree oil and
four drops of
argan oil into five tablespoons of aloe
vera gel
apply this mask on the hair strands and
on the scalp as well
wash with lukewarm water after three
hours do this once a week for at least a
couple of months
number five coconut oil coconut oil is
considered as a very good skin care
product
coconut oil has excellent moisturization
properties that can help to treat
dandruff and dry skin simultaneously
coconut oil has also been traditionally
used as a natural antimicrobial product
one of the key ingredients of coconut
oil is lauric acid
which helps to combat malassezia the
fungi is responsible for dandruff
the best way to use coconut oil is to
apply one to two hours before you
shampoo
apply it directly on the scalp and leave
it on for a few hours to
make sure the oil has chance to
penetrate your hair and skin
then rinse it off thoroughly with a mild
shampoo
so friends these are five effective home
remedies that you can try if you're
suffering from dandruff
i've included links to some of the best
products in the description box down
below so you can check them out
i hope you liked the video see you in
the next video